hi I'm Anna Akana and I love creating
for the last 10 years I've done a weekly
online comedy show with an emphasis on
personal development mental health
awareness and the joy of having many
cats along the way I've made short films
scripted shows sketches a book several
standup tours and created animated
poetry I've also been working on a bunch
of secret projects like the short when
I've wanted to die a stop-motion
animated movie called dolor and drumroll
please an album I love creating and I've
always been very transparent with you
guys that I take on sponsored deals in
order to have the money to fund passion
projects pay my crew well and expand and
explore as an artist because as much as
I love making the weekly show here I do
want to do bigger and better things and
grow as a filmmaker but bigger and
better things are also more expensive
naturally so if you like what I do I
feel comfortable asking you for $1 a
month to support my endeavors if you'd
like to donate more great there are some
awesome perks you can check out here and
if you'd like everything to be free like
it has been for the past decade then
awesome no pressure I will keep making
things and thank you for watching your
attention and this overly saturated
world of content is valuable and I
appreciate it but for those of you
comfortable donating $12 more a year I
have started a patreon page and all the
money will go towards passion projects
like music videos animated poetry pilots
and short films thank you so much for
your support I'm Anna Akana stay awesome
Gotham